Stephen Hawking is in the news today he
has an exciting new result hoppy has
proven that God does not exist well
that's not exactly it but you still
might be wondering what exactly is it
that Stephen Hawking a mathematical
physicist has to tell us about the
existence of God the answer is he does
actually have a point to make he's using
ideas from modern science to make a
point about what we need to assume in
order to explain the universe around us
in particular that science has
progressed to the point where you don't
need to go outside the universe to
explain the universe you can have a
self-contained understanding of not only
how things work here in the lab but why
the universe itself exists partly
Hawking's argument is based on really
deep ideas in fundamental physics he's
using general relativity Einstein's
theory of gravity with quantum mechanics
our idea that nature at a fundamental
level is a little bit uncertain there
can be fluctuations things can happen
spontaneously the point about general
relativity is that I'm Stein says that
space and time are flexible they're not
set once and for all as in Isaac
Newton's universe they can change they
can move they can even come into
existence and the best part is the
energy of the entire universe according
to Einstein is exactly zero you can
create a compact self-contained universe
without needing any energy at all
there's no limit on how many universes
you can make you can either have a
universe be created out of some
pre-existing parent space-time or the
universe could just come into existence
out of nothing now you take that and you
add to that quantum mechanics the idea
that if something can happen it is going
to happen the idea there's a space of
possibilities in the university explores
the entire space if that's true just
wait long enough a universe like ours
will come into existence so the Hawking
says is that the ancient question why is
there something rather than nothing
has been answered by modern physics now
you might be skeptical that this answer
is a good one you might not believe that
we understand why there is something
rather than nothing but that's not
really the point the point is that you
could imagine an understanding of the
why it came into existence without ever
leaving the laws of nature without ever
invoking some divine some supernatural
being the universe could just obey its
own laws it could be a natural physical
material universe obeying the laws of
physics and that can be a complete
explanation of everything so you might
say that a lot of proof that God doesn't
exist
whatsoever God can still exist even if
he didn't create the universe or have
anything to do with creating the
universe and of course that is true
Hawking it not true that God does not
exist what he's pointing out is that as
far as science is concerned there's no
role for God in understanding the
universe as we see it you can still
believe in God if you want as long as
you believe in a God that just doesn't
do anything to the universe God did not
create the universe did not influence
the universe in any way that's the
lesson of modern science the universe
runs by itself we can choose to live in
that universe we can choose to imagine
there's all sorts of other things that
we don't see in the universe but we can
get along just fine with the universe
and nothing outside